sur la situation et puis les réactions à
l'accord de normalisation entre le maroc
et israël le front polisario soutenu par
l'algérie montent au créneau la russie
condamne ce coup diplomatique de donald
train qui vous reconnaît la souveraineté
marocaine sur le sahara occidental de
son côté le maroc assure la poursuite de
son engagement en faveur de la cause
palestinienne
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france à bruxelles en
ce moment les négociations pour parvenir
à un accord commercial post break site
se poursuivre même si le pessimisme est
de mise
depuis le royaume uni aujourd'hui boris
johnson a jugé très probable l'échec des
discussions le premier ministre qui
s'est déplacé à bruxelles mercredi soir
on le rappelle mais du côté de
l'allemagne et de l'irlande on affirme
qu'un deal est difficile mais encore
possible leur chef de la diplomatie
refuse de baisser les bras
à défaut de compromis d'ici dimanche les
relations commerciales entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni seront
régies par les règles de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
les négociations qui se déroulent dans
le cadre du sommet européen s'achève ce
soir
outre le bric site on notera quand même
quelques avancées notamment sur le plan
de relance post qu'ovide à la pologne et
la hongrie ont accepté de lever leur
veto wesley avec un wally bennani et
quentin bancaire
les visages fermés et pas décidé les
plus grands dirigeants européens réunis
à bruxelles l'union européenne
à la croisée des chemins celui du
compromis ou celui d'une crise majeure
les vingt-sept ont choisi l'unité le
plan de relance européen historique
décidée en juillet entre aujourd'hui
dans le concret nous venons d'adopter un
accord robuste sur le mécanisme à mettre
en oeuvre dans le respect de l'état de
droit
l'europe avance unis et porte ces
valeurs les dirigeants européens n'ont
pas tardé à débloquer ce jeudi le plan
de relance posco vide estimé à 750
milliards d'euros votée l'été dernier un
accord dont s'est réjoui le président du
conseil européen
charles michel maintenant nous pouvons
lancer la mise en oeuvre et reconstruire
nos économies
notre plan de relance historique va
faire avancer nos transition verte et
numérique une année 2020 a oublié et des
perspectives à construire pour l'avenir
les contours du budget de l'union
européenne pour les sept prochaines
années
finalement dessiner la hongrie et la
pologne réticente souhaitait éviter
toute condition arbitraire pour un
versement des fonds aujourd'hui nous
nous battons pour l'unité de notre
continent commun à nous devons nous
comporter de manière raisonnable et
trouver un moyen d'adopter des approches
fiable et de faire triompher le bon sens
pour fournir des services de santé en
cas de pandémie aux personnes qui en ont
besoin et pour apporter une aide
financière aux pays qui sont réellement
dans le besoin pour aider leurs
populations et l'environnement également
au coeur des négociations
les 27 se sont mis d'accord pour réduire
leurs émissions de co2 d'au moins 55%
d'ici 2030 et pierre-emmanuel toman est
avec nous pour en parler il est
consultant géopolitique fondateur du
site internet euros continent
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors ce plan de
relance est là finalement donc a été
adopté avec malgré les réserves à
ambroise et polonaises que s'est il
passé pour ce pour ce déclic lors de ce
sommet européen est bien un compromis a
été possible parce que un compromis qui
a été négocié par l'allemagne qui a la
présidence de l'union européenne a
permis de diluer
cette application de la conditionnalité
pour la dépense des fonds européens en
rapport avec l'état de droit c'est à
dire que la pologne la hongrie s'estime
gagnant dans cette négociation parce que
évidemment là la conditionnalité
juridique est toujours là mais sa mise
en oeuvre sera extrêmement difficile
parce qu'il ya des barrières des délais
notamment avec un passage avec la cour
de justice européenne qui va qui sans
doute permettra la mise en oeuvre de
cette conditionnalité ce qu'il sera très
difficile donc mais cela ne résout pas
en fait les désaccords fondamentaux sur
la finalité du projet européen
parce que derrière ces discussions
juridiques se cache en fait des des
fractures beaucoup plus profonde entre
états membres sur le devenir de l'union
européenne par rapport à cet état de
droit c'est à dire d'un côté des
gouvernements qui met en avant un projet
européen qui en fait ne défend pas
l'europe en tant que tel mais la
démocratie libérale et multiculturaliste
qui est plutôt d'inspiration d'ailleurs
américaine dans l'espace euro atlantique
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale et
puis les anciens états membres
enfin les anciens états membres du bloc
communiste qui sont devenus qui sont
devenus et armand l'union européenne et
qui ont une défense plus civilisationnel
de l'europe et qui considèrent que en
fait
cette union européenne doit défendre
avant tout l'europe comme une entité qu
civilisationnel et non pas des normes
d'état de droit qui sont plus liés à des
normes de gouvernance de la démocratie
libérale et multiculturel harris et
multiculturalisme cc question n'est pas
réglée on verra à l'usagé lors des
différents comment ces mécanismes de
disputes pourront mettre pourront être
mises en oeuvre mais ce sera assez
difficile et les disputes vont rester
ont fait que l'union européenne a pris
l'habitude on l'a vu plusieurs fois par
le passé justement de conditionnel de
poser des conditions justement à anne
aide notamment envers les pays du sud
ce compromis qui a été trouvé lors de ce
sommet à bruxelles
est ce que c'est un tournant historique
est ce qu'on peut considérer que c'est
un tournant historique
non je ne pense pas puisque c'est un
comme tous les compromis européen ils
sont temporaires précaire et c'est un
compromis institutionnel et juridique et
ça ne résout pas la question de fond sur
les sur le modèle européen les finalités
européenne et donc il y aura toujours
dispute entre les gouvernements des pays
de l'union européenne principalement
aujourd'hui l'allemagne la france qui
défendent la démocratie libérale et puis
les pays d'europe centrale comme la
pologne allons à la hongrie qui ne
veulent pas que les fonds soient
conditionnées par rapport à des normes
des normes de gouvernance et en
particulier le qu'on leur impose par
exemple une défense accrue des minorités
alors qu'ils défendent la nation
chrétienne avec moins d'immigration la
gestion des frontières aussi les
questions de plus juridique sur l'état
de droit par exemple le
mais les modèles d'enseignement par
exemple les universités qui s'implantent
en hongrie par exemple l'université
soros a t'elle le droit de de tout
enseigner y compris le faire du
prosélytisme libéral je dirais du point
de vue des hongrois alors que les
hongrois veulent garder la maîtrise du
contenu de l'enseignement pour préserver
la nation toutes ces questions vont
rester des questions sensibles et
d'autres questions aux six d'autres
biais d'options qui concerne videmment
ce plan de relance est 150 milliards
d'euros comment et financer ce plan de
relance et puis aussi la question de la
répartition aussi des fonds oui alors
derrière cette répartition il ya une
lutte pour le pouvoir évidemment les
états membres qui seront contributeurs
nets évidemment veulent un contrôle sur
ces fonds qui seront dépensés dans l'est
dans les états membres qui recevront ces
fonds qui ne seront pas contributeurs
nets alors les contributeurs nets seront
surtout l'allemagne les pays-bas mais
aussi la france et donc ils veulent
garder le pouvoir sur ces transferts
financiers
ces transferts financiers aussi ne
seront pas si gigantesque par rapport à
l'année normes crise que nous allons
devoir à laquelle nous allons devoir
faire face à l'avenir avec ces
restrictions à cause du coc vide etc
font aussi il est douteux qui lui
permettront temporairement évidemment de
faire tourner la machine l'économie mais
cela ne résoudra pas le lait les
fractures qui se sont développées depuis
l'introduction de l'euro entre les pays
du nord et les pays du sud la
désindustrialisation et on voit bien que
le scellé dans la mise en oeuvre de ces
fonds ce sont surtout les pays du nord
qui vont être gagnant parce qu'ils ont
les moyens de mettre en en de mettre en
oeuvre des fonds des fonds pour sauver
leurs économies et les pays du sud
même si temporairement ils pourront
sauver les meubles ne pourront pas se
réindustrialiser parce que tout se sait
fonds de relance se produit dans dans
selon le paradigme de la société ouverte
des économies ouvertes et parce que
l'allemagne et les pays du nord veulent
continuer à exporter vers la chine vers
les états unis et donc les problèmes
après le kobe devons rester entier merci
beaucoup à vous pierre est manal commun
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant en géopolitique fondateur du
site euros continent au sommet du au
menu du sommet européen également le
dossier turc en cause les opérations
d'exploration gazière venait dans les
eaux grecques et chypriote en
méditerranée est divisé les vingt-sept
ont adopté des sanctions minimales
contre ankara en voix slaves et grégoire
bosser bruxelles durcit le ton avec
ankara dans le cadre du sommet de
l'union européenne les vingt-sept se
sont mis d'accord dans la nuit de jeudi
à vendredi pour une première phase de
sanction qui pourrait en appeler
d'autres
les mesures décidées sont des sanctions
individuelles et des mesures
supplémentaires pourront être décidées
si la turquie poursuit ses actions
motif de ces sanctions les activités
turques en méditerranée orientale dans
des zones maritime disputée avec la
grèce un navire turquie à semer la
discorde en menant ces derniers mois des
recherches d'hydrocarbures cette
décision européenne suscite la colère du
président turc recep tayyip erdogan
alors que le navire en question à
regagner les côtes turques depuis près
de deux semaines les agendas de
sanctions imposées en raison d'objectifs
politiques et de fondement et
rationnelle sont nuisibles pour toutes
les parties
tu rentres à l'étude ça n'apporte aucun
avantage ou profit une nouvelle peu
réjouissante pour une économie turque
déjà en berne à laquelle il faut ajouter
les sanctions américaines
conséquence d'un contentieux entre
washington et ankara à propos d'un
système de missiles russes acquis par la
turquie
l'exécutif a tranché le déconfinement du
15 décembre sera plus strict que prévu
la situation sanitaire actuelle ne
permet pas la france de s'affranchir de
toutes ces restrictions et le
gouvernement veut tout faire pour éviter
un troisième un confinement dès mardi
donc l'instauration d'un couvre-feu de
20h à 6h seule exception et ce sera
l'unique le soir de noël elle les
établissements recevant du public comme
les musées les théâtres cinémas et
salles de sport reste fermé trois
semaines supplémentaires quelques
allègements tout de même afin de
l'attestation dérogatoire en journée et
déplacements de nouveau autorisée
partout en france
un déconfinement très strictes donc qui
nous attends je vous le disais avec ceux
des confinement et pour les étudiants ça
va pas être évidemment facile aussi
puisque le conseil d'état a rejeté la
demande de reprise urgente des cours en
présentiel dans les universités à le
juge des référés estime que l'accès à
l'enseignement supérieur est garantie
par l'enseignement à distance et la
possibilité de se rendre sur site sur
rendez vous pour alexis poulain
éditorialistes les jeunes qui sont ceux
qui souffrent le plus de cette crise
écoutez le fin je crois qu'il faut
refuser ce monde là il est extrêmement
dangereux et à un pays un continent qui
sacrifie sa jeunesse n'a aucun avenir et
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que les
jeunes sont simplement des sacrifiés à
la fois pour la dette qu'on est en train
d'accumuler qui seront obligés de
rembourser si jamais les responsables
comme monsieur villeroy de galhau ou
madame lagarde sont toujours aux
manettes dans quelques années mais aussi
sur cette façon de se sociabiliser
devenu impossible
devenue dangereuse avec la phobie
finalement de l'autre avec cette
distanciation sociale parce que ce virus
qui n'est pas dangereux pour la grande
majorité des jeunes
eh bien il est dangereux pour la société
on a mis à l'arrêt parce qu'on est
évidemment il est dangereux de virus
mais vraiment et aucune mesure n'est
décidé en faveur en direction des plus
jeunes qui eux sont vraiment ceux qui
souffrent le plus de cette crise
et on l'a appris ce matin les
laboratoires français et britanniques
sanofi gsk ont pris du retard leur
vaccin ne sera prêt qu'à la fin à 2021
les choses s'accélèrent en tout cas pour
à leurs concurrents aux états unis un
comité indépendant a demandé à
l'autorité des denrées alimentaires et
des médicaments de donner son feu vert
au vaccin de l'alliance germano
américaine pfizer biotech est la
campagne de vaccination pourrait débuter
dès la semaine prochaine là bas ce dont
se félicite le vice-président américain
mike pence vers 12h10 nord les gens
méritent de savoir que nous ne sommes
plus qu'à quelques jours de ce qui sera
je crois le début de la fin de la
pandémie coronavirus son amérique
littéralement de quelques petits jours
nous croyons que nous obtiendrons le feu
vert pour commencer à distribuer et
administrer des millions de doses du
vaccin et la reverra les campagnes de
vaccination les le royaume uni 6 et déjà
lancé la russie aussi avec une première
étape destinée aux travailleurs à risque
est maintenant au tour de la population
des détails en images
regardez les russes peuvent désormais se
faire vacciner
moscou qui prend part à la course au
vaccin contre le coc vite 19 possède
désormais les infrastructures et
l'industrie pour relever le défi
je sais que les premiers points de
vaccination ouvrent dès aujourd'hui
leurs portes
ils sont définis dans chaque région et
leur nombre augmentera parallèlement à
l'approvisionnement en vaccins je
demande encore une fois au sujet de la
fédération de russie d'assurer le
fonctionnement des points de vaccination
est bien entendu d'accorder une
attention particulière à leur travail
pendant les jours fériés
surtout du 1er janvier au 10 janvier
et pour que tous ceux qui le souhaitent
puissent se faire vacciner moscou qui a
annoncé sa collaboration avec le
laboratoire britannique astrazeneca doit
par ailleurs mené une autre série
d'essais cliniques
les russes plaide en faveur d'une
participation des pays de l'union
économique eurasiatique ces choses
actuellement la possibilité de livrer le
vaccin russe spoutnik vais dans les pays
de l'union est en cours d'examen
d'ailleurs le deuxième vaccin et piva
corona a déjà été enregistré le
troisième vaccin on est à l'étape finale
des essais nous sommes bien évidemment
intéressé à ce que les cinq partenaires
de l'union participe aux essais
scientifiques et cliniques du vaccin
russe et à l'organisation de sa co
production en prison comme d'autres
vaccins spoutnik v a parfois été attaqué
à l'échelle internationale sur sa
fiabilité
le porte parole du kremlin assure
cependant qu'il s'agit d'un vaccin
fiable et efficace
par ailleurs la russie le laboratoire
astrazeneca ont annoncé leur
collaboration ils effectueront lt effet
qu'il est commun combinant leurs deux
vaccins les détails avec notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman la
pandémie du courant des virus trouvera
désormais sur sa route en partenariat
inédit le j1 pharmaceutique britannique
astrazeneca a annoncé un accord avec le
centre de recherche russe gamaleya
développeurs du vaccin spoutnik v pour
explorer le potentiel d'une combinaison
alliant son vaccin est le remède russe
il s'agira de booster l'efficacité du
vaccin britannique avec en composant
russe des essais cliniques doivent
commencer avant la fin 2020
l'accord a été conclu après que les
scientifiques russes se sont adressés
sur twitter astrazeneca pour leur
proposer cette collaboration au kremlin
on met en garde contre la politisation
des partenariats scientifiques face à la
pandémie
écoutez cette volonté a été remarqué par
le kremlin mais pas seulement
on la voit comme on
10 à l'oeil nu la compétition est dur et
si la concurrence est honnête c'est
positif
il ne doit y avoir de concurrence trop
forte sur ce marché si premièrement
celle concurrence est politisé et si
deuxièmement des méthodes douteuses pour
discréditer notre vaccin sont employés
c'est autre chose
cependant c'est effectivement le premier
vaccin mis au point il est fiable
c'est un bon vaccin on le demande les
géants pharmaceutiques de certains pays
utilisent effectivement parfois à des
moyens qui ne sont pas très appréciable
pour empêcher des exportations de notre
vaccin dans différents pays
on le sait bien pour ce qui est des
chiffres de l'épidémie de coronavirus en
russie le nombre de nouveaux cas
quotidiens ne dépasse toujours pas
trente mille moscou épicentre de
l'épidémie un registre moins de huit
mille nouveaux cas ce vendredi la
vaccination de masse qui a débuté dans
la capitale la semaine dernière se
poursuivent désormais dans toutes les
régions du pays
la vaccination sera également possible
pour la population russe du 1er au 10
janvier 2021 jours traditionnellement
férié en russie
il est en fin de mandat mais reste actif
sur le plan diplomatique comme un pied
de nez à son rival joe biden donald
trump a reconnu la souveraineté du maroc
sur le sahara occidental en échange
d'une normalisation a des relations
entre le royaume chérifien et israël
dénonce une décision dénoncée par le
front polisario condamné également par
la russie y ont fait le point avec un
jardinet mariche un référendum
d'autodétermination prévu par l'onu doit
avoir lieu depuis plusieurs années pour
laisser le choix à la population du
sahara occidental l'indépendance ou le
rattachement à rabat mais les
négociations menées par les nations
unies impliquant le maroc le front
polisario l'algérie et la mauritanie
sont suspendus depuis mars 2019
une faille dans laquelle les états unis
se sont empressés de s'engouffrer en
reconnaissant la souveraineté marocaine
sur ce territoire contesté une violation
de la charte des nations unies aux
services de l'actuel diplomatie
américaine qui tente de pousser un
maximum de pays arabes à normaliser
leurs relations avec israël
une situation dénoncée avec force par le
mouvement indépendantiste sahraoui
la décision de trump ne change rien à la
nature juridique de la question
sahraouie car la communauté
internationale ne reconnaît pas la
souveraineté du maroc sur le sahara
occidental
elle constitue une violation flagrante
de la charte des nations unies et des
textes fondateurs de l'union africaine
et freine les efforts de la communauté
internationale visant à trouver une
solution pacifique au conflit entre la
république sahraouie et le royaume du
maroc
la russie a elle aussi dénoncé ce
vendredi la décision américaine estimant
qu'elle sort complètement du cadre du
droit international
ce que les américains ont fait ici c'est
une décision unilatérale qui sort
complètement du cadre du droit
international
de son côté le secrétaire général de
l'onu antonio gutiérrez a fait savoir
que la position des nations unies était
inchangé sur le sahara occidental
la solution à cette question peut
toujours être trouvé sur la base des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité
si le polisario soutenu par l'algérie
réclame un référendum
d'autodétermination le maroc qui
contrôlent plus des deux tiers de ce
vaste territoire riche en ressources
naturelles proposé lui
plan d'autonomie sous sa souveraineté
contrepartie de cette reconnaissance
américaine l'officialisation des
rapports entre rabat et tel aviv un
accord de nouveau conclue sous la
médiation de donald trump le premier
ministre israélien l'a immédiatement
salué j'ai toujours cru que cette
journée historique deviendrait réalité
un jour j'ai toujours oeuvré pour cela
je veux remercier donald trump pour ses
efforts extraordinaires pour avoir mené
la paix en israël et les peuples du
moyen-orient
après les émirats arabes unis le bahreïn
et le soudan le maroc devient le
quatrième pays arabes depuis août
dernier à promettre l'établissement de
relations diplomatiques avec l'état
hébreu et le front polisario entend
poursuivre le combat salon ou bi
bouchard et à bâcher représentant du
front pour les are you pour l'europe
pour nous c'est une décision qui
constitue une violation flagrante de la
charte de l'onu ainsi que une attaque
directe même contre li na fait qu'elle
ou le dpi au conflit et le royaume du
maroc et la république sahraouie y
siègent en toute légalité
cette décision contribuera certainement
à déstabiliser la région et davantage et
elle aura pas hier par ailleurs un
impact négatif sur le futur delà des
efforts de l'onu pour résoudre le
conflit du sahara occidental puisqu'elle
donne un message erroné au maroc qui va
l'encourager davantage de de continuer à
défier la légalité internationale etc
mais l'instabilité et l'insécurité dans
la région
enfin le lancement de la future monnaie
west african échos être reporté sans
précision de date c'est toujours le
franc cfa donc mais mercredi la france a
ratifié l'accord de coopération
monétaire conclu le 21 décembre à 2019
entre paris le mois à la zone monétaire
ouest africaine paris actes donc la
parité fixe avec l'euro
loin de faire l'unanimité au sein de la
région
on voit cela avec françois pesquet beach
le 21 décembre dernier à abidjan en côte
d'ivoire
emmanuel macron annonce la fin prochaine
du franc cfa
une réforme historique majeur selon ses
mots acté avec son homologue ivoirien
alassane ouattara représentant les huit
pays de l'union économique et monétaire
ouest africaine et je suis très heureux
aujourd'hui d'être à ses côtés pour
ensemble annoncé cette réforme
historique majeur cette réforme vise à
franchir ensemble une nouvelle étape
concrètement avec cette réforme le franc
cfa change de nom pour laisser place à
l'écho autre changement la banque
centrale des états d'afrique de l'ouest
ne devra plus déposer la moitié de ses
réserves de change auprès du trésor
français
une obligation perçue comme une
dépendance humiliante vis-à-vis de la
france par les détracteurs du franc cfa
paris retire ses administrateurs de la
bceao mais se réserve le droit de
revenir dans une instance de décision en
cas de crise en revanche pas de
changement
la france reste garante de la monnaie
qui conserve sa parité avec l'euro cet
importun trop fort 20 50
notre volonté de construire notre futur
de manière responsable afin d'attirer
les investissements privés métier d
emploi et de poursuivre le développement
économique de nos pays
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans cette
étape de la réforme
les chefs d'état de l'uemoa ont
également décidé de maintenir la parité
fixe avec leur la nouvelle monnaie
l'écho devait être lancée en 2020 mais
sa mise en place a été repoussée à une
date indéfinie
un calendrier qui semblait au delà de la
crise sanitaire déjà peu réaliste
il aurait fallu en quelques mois créer
une banque centrale fabriquer pièces et
billets ou encore adapté des systèmes
informatiques et les administrations
ce que l'europe a mis une dizaine
d'années à faire pour lancer son euro et
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver en
vie
dans 30 minutes restez avec nous sur la
défense
[Musique]
et y'a pas une façon plus